[Music]
over the past six months my team and I
have been all over the country checking
out your best restaurant nominations and
tonight my competition continues this
time to find the best North African
North African food is like no other the
careful layering of different spices
results in wonderfully aromatic dishes
one mouthful can really transport into a
completely different world the best
restaurants will mix gutsy flavors with
rich sweet and intricate combinations of
spices to deliver dishes that will
excite all the senses I'm hoping
tonight's contenders will show what this
fantastic regime has to offer tonight
my two favorite North African
restaurants will battle it out for a
place in the semi-finals from central
London its Momo that glamorous celebrity
haunt as renowned for its vibrant
atmosphere as its food but what mama
shows that look at Table two
you've got a great team and a great
feeling and great passion and we we're
gonna win it the Merman machine is
taking on a zoo from Hammersmith West
London a small family-run restaurant
loved by the locals as he sat on lamb oh
yes I think I am to this I would love to
see someone challenging me I predict a
furious fights as to London restaurants
take each other on in three
extraordinary challenges
the first is every restaurants worst
nightmare 30 hungry diners who arrive an
order all at the same time first they're
heading for Momo tucked away behind
London's Regent Street is run by a
passionate northerner Dave he's been
cooking since the age of 15 and he now
heads up a brigade of 26 chefs this
session has also been visited by some
serious a-listers from Madonna to Greta
the Paltrow and if they can look after
those kind of customers my diner today
are in for a real treat hey Davis Gordon
how are you faring how are you very good
very good so the secret success of
Momo's knew what we all work together as
a team and we create and create an
atmosphere and hopefully delicious food
yeah open 13 years ago
it's excellent food stylish surroundings
and party atmosphere quickly established
Momo as one of London's most fashionable
restaurants
as soon as you enter it's like a theater
you come in you see the atmosphere you
see the deck or you see the buzz you
want to get involved we get lots of film
stars lots of footballers politicians
lots of you know people want to go
through the back door what I love most
about Momo is you feel comfortable
straight away and the atmosphere is sexy
I need one lamb tagine not copy under
three minutes yet 37 year old David has
cooked in kitchens all over the world
Cook has been my life from from the age
of 14 and a half 15 I wait table 50
tagine lamb solo steak medium rare yeah
Juiz travels in Morocco
today we fell in love with North African
food I love the passion Moroccan cuisine
I think it's a great flavors everybody
thinks American cuisine is couse person
tagine its vast assisted for seven years
my French sous chef Philippe David gives
traditional recipes his own personal
touch doesn't look like a creme brulee
[Music]
that's delicious
only a Yorkshire would [ __ ] fry our
creme brulee but it works David that's
some of the best food I've tasted so far
in this competition make sure that you
give my diners the exact experience
you've just delivered to me now Momo is
about to be put through his paces
because my ravenous diners have arrived
all expecting food and service fit for
London's glitterati
hello welcome and the service shouldn't
pose a problem as front of house manager
Murad has a team of nine waiters this
place deals with big numbers easily so
they can become a little complacent
because there's only 30 diners coming
and sometimes questions get bad
reputation for just looking after the
a-listers and forgetting the real
customers
so first take it on you know one scallop
on Miche means only one fish in a day
two mobiles medium as first orders
arrive head chef David directs his
brigade like a conductor with an
orchestra
don't start 14 door start 6 year please
don't put all 9 past here at same time
police don't know crispy that past year
two minutes busted make sure the first
plate for tables go fast and slow down
there are three starters Moroccan
aubergine caviar with mixed peppers wood
pigeon passier a delicate North African
pie and scholars with aubergine chutney
and a fresh herb Sal sir David's on fire
and the first starters are out within
minutes
any problems anywhere any main course
already it's the two ladies on the end
here
don't throw their main course out as
quick yeah hold it back a little bit
David is doing his best to control the
flow of food sent Table one I'll slow
down on 14 and 6 but it's front-of-house
who need to pay service and make sure
every table gets their food at the right
time I've just told the team to slow
down slow down it's not a race very good
flavor combination light tasting some of
my diners are less impressed
gentlemen the pigeon pasta how's that a
nice picture dry and not enough bitching
damn it was just bit too dry and just I
did like it people willing for me okay
the pity party is really inventive you
got three layers you've got like a
rolling compost it's been bitching and
like scrambled eggs on top with almonds
it's not dry everything it needs a bit
more pigeon in there
[Music]
for mains there's a choice of three
smoked lamb shank with couscous and
spicy sausages fish wrapped in vine
leaves with white beans and that North
African staple chicken tagine version
you know terra cotta dish of course are
very traditional a lot of the way you
taste every Tajima is going out he may
be doing everyday but you're still
tasting it every time the kitchen is
focused while front of house look busy
but don't seem coordinated give it you
have six of motivating patients with the
status I mean you're waiting there are
lots of waiters but it doesn't seem like
the managers are controlling service and
some of my diners slip through the net
Roger six their starters what's top
saber-6 come in about three minutes
premature just slowing down so we're not
get everything kind of wait at center
yes finding that balance one table
complain it's too far one table complain
lose too slow cigarettes just try to
find that balance too who hasn't had
their main courses you know when you get
thirty customers at once you want to
save it like a party it's very hard to
pace yourself coming they're not as
short-staffed
they seem to have a manager four
teaspoons and manage for the bread the
manager for the lid the couscous so
service should be impeccable today so
they should get that balance right you
can't serve a table two courses with one
table nothing
that's bad management and far too many
chiefs in dining room and not enough in
news is
there's more managers in this time room
there are grains of [ __ ] crystals
we definitely come again we said that as
soon as the main course came out tonight
yes sir
it's a lovely feeling here we've been
made to feel very comfortable did you
take quite well to commit to receive my
food I didn't like waiting that long to
listen what we've done is nice lunch is
over but I'm disappointed that service
was inconsistent for some of my diners
timing was all over the shop and that
was down to the the suited and booted
the managers far too many managers and a
real lack of communication with the
kitchen and thank God David was on fire
because we have too many managers on the
floor that couldn't spot who can serve
what okay big test that one you're used
to big numbers so 30 diners should have
been a walk in the park how did I go for
you weight very well I really enjoyed
you know nice was a great burst great
atmosphere
yeah great atmosphere my biggest concern
today was the fact that there was one
table next to the big table that had
their starters of main courses and the
six top had nothing to eat when somebody
hasn't got food in front of them and
they're eyeing up the table next door to
them they get jealous we had two
complaints capacity for the pigeon if
anything maybe not so small in terms of
dice so they can identify what they've
got on the fork is a piece of pigeon he
didn't say enough desserts I thought
that was the best creme brulee I've ever
tasted in a decade share the starter but
make sure you save room for that dessert
that's how good they are well done
[Music]
it's nice that feedback and if it's
negative or not good feedback you keep
showing your toes dancing we've got a
great team and a great feeling and great
passion and we we're gonna win it we're
here to win it's the North African heat
of my nationwide restaurant competition
and 30 hungry diners are about to
descend on my second competitor here at
Hammersmith is one of the best-kept
secrets in town this is a zoo a romantic
small North African restaurant run by a
lovely husband and wife team Chris and
Chris now although it's small is
punching way above his weight a serious
contender go all the way in this
competition focus good to see you too
look how small this place is this look
at it got your small and thin and
good-looking evil bear scary
what are they all there for next the
takeaway I would take you okay former
headmistress Chris and I chef husband
Chris open a zoo 11 years ago they work
seven days a week running this 35 cover
restaurant with the help of just five
other members of staff
I've got Constantine our main course
comes to a large place please I think
apparel to this restaurant I do love
working hard
I mean you manage once a century to have
sort of day off where you want to stand
by but you feel like guilty why am i
awake and that guilt makes your day not
a day off you cook every day and it's
it's a passion it's never a job for you
yes it is what's the secret behind the
success of your food my wife your wife
Chris I don't know what to do without
her to be honest she's very very good
support and believes really in what I do
for that I love you more
Krishna to cook authentic North African
food and his grandmother's knee in
Algeria this is the food of my childhood
when I was living in Algeria when she
was cooking she's always you know having
you next to her and you see how how you
do she's doing it and he looks like he's
still cooking with her pot to what was
last time you bought a new pan that's a
good question what we changed in 10
years in this kitchen
not much where's the fridge I've got
this one here okay all right well okay
great they're delicious
merci very rare you see sardines today
everyone thinks it's a oily friction no
one wants it but that's delicious well
there's very few chefs I know with a
missioning star that can cook like he
can I'm very passionate about my food I
mean it makes me happy
Chris is such a perfectionist insist on
over seen everything that's cooked in
his tiny kitchen sorry for taking over
no grace like given we want to check
everything from the scratch even I think
I worked with him 20 years he's gonna
never gonna change
I do strive to be the best cream oh I
will carry on doing it until till the
end because this is it this is my life
and these lives about to be turned
upside down by my next challenge
I kept my Dinah's gonna be here and just
under five minutes yeah only watching
everything I'll be in the kitchen
watching how you work I'll be in the
dining room scrutinizing everything your
reputation is legendary tonight it's on
the line Chris was just two hours to
cook and serve two courses for 30
customers quite a pressure for a small
restaurant and the clock starts now
hello hello hope you enjoy your evening
with us thank you thank you it's great
fish to show you one lamb card it's
quickly become clear that is not just
the kitchen that's stuck in a time warp
Chris so when you take the orders
there's no computers is all handwritten
tickets are you much prefer that as
opposed to the 21st century it works if
it works don't change it it's my dang in
a plaster Chris has put the wrong table
number on an order and now a second
order has come in for the same table
hold it hold it hold it so long first
era of the evening that that's done
twice don't worry
thank you how'd you prefer this by hand
written like that is it easy for you I
got used to it but if they two tables of
fours confusing right yes it is if you
had a computer you wouldn't have these
problems no that was my fault I should
is your head chef here's your toy boy
look after it there is a choice of three
starters marinated sardines with spicy
sauce grill pepper salad with Merguez
sausages now love week and a break at an
isiand speciality pastry filled with
tuna potato and a soft egg then deep
fried crisp these have been here for 2
minutes the egg yolk is runny and I want
them to experience that I will tell
another damn 115 away service please
Jesus you put in that egg yolks should
sort of run all over the tuna yeah
really really good not too spicy not too
sweet really well with the starters over
Christmas 30 complex mains to cook on
his tiny stove there are 3 choices of
tagine buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh
cod with king prawns and seafood chicken
with olives and preserved lemons or lamb
in a spicy sauce handed down from his
grandmother already although he's got a
sous chef and two others to help him
just as I thought
perfectionist Chris wants to do
everything himself if he carries on like
this food will be delayed
[Music]
and why don't you do the Christmas chili
the course good yeah but he's doing
everything just in the plates can you
dress the place you've got the one
working their pens everywhere one two
three of you do nothing
yeah it is the chef he doesn't want to
say bombers to the Bombers oh okay honey
if you a compulsion cook wait yeah
through the bars
it's more spaced out here there is in
there you've got to take some of the
responsibility away from him come on
it's incredible I mean I thought I was a
control freak
Chris takes it to a completely different
level and he just cannot delegate you're
a control freak
well I'm not the control thick but what
you doing everything no well no well I
just want to open up and talk the danger
one person didn't get a body oh [ __ ] me
I'm sure you get your own finger bowl
and do you need them to get you a finger
Bowl do you do ya
one finger Bowl plays for the fish to
gene this is getting ridiculous front of
house would be help in the kitchen not
hindering finger ball
oh it's potentially catastrophic because
he's so used to that one-man band top
the two stations again you had the drums
the guitar they all be on the mouth and
he's just playing everything and
everyone's running around and crazy no
she's not be friends and goes in there
chops of peppers there's got about 12
things going on the stone I mean the
guy's a freak you can see him kindly
organizing his own criminal jumping the
coughing and saying goodbye to her and
saying the prayer at the end close the
lid Yesi of Wow
both evolve thank you don't bother the
kitchen for nothing
excellent coming up - halfway there and
it won't offload his concentration
why is he paying all those members of
staff and he's doing everything on his
shoulders
Chris not letting his brigade near the
stove means some customers are still
waiting for the mains this guy won't
accept help from anyone
I've got to get through to him somehow
can you start talking to your brigades
boy
okay guys hello how are you come on hi
Ali let's get on with it
I've got the fish you've got everything
Wow this last table look at me for two
seconds is there any chance that you can
stand over here right I let your
sous-chef right
your second chef in your third chef all
right cook the last table go outside and
take some fresh air just out there just
just a few minutes you come over here
and you gonna get some fresh air out out
right let them do it okay just the last
table I'll kill you guys if you don't do
it properly you're gonna be dead in two
weeks if you continue like this let it
go
okay last time how long listen for three
minutes
[Music]
come on guys
give one more leave him alone ha it's
fine that's something I have to work on
but you know when your love cooking
that's what you do fish very tough very
savoury mince really come string put a
flavor a little bit spice really nice
the booze wonderful the place we've got
so much charm so much parent oh such a
great welcome service is over and my
diners are leaving happy
okay right first of all service unique
ladies well done thank you
yeah even down to the handwritten
tickets okay the first thing when in
second ticket to doubles of foot doesn't
matter and that's for the kitchen where
do I start with you food is delicious
sublime just amazing my biggest problem
is you
I want thousands more customers to enjoy
your food but you won't be around if you
don't open up and delegate I will you'll
be surprised to what it does messy well
done
seriously welcome really good what was
good for me is realizing that I should I
must delegate you take it on board put
it this way I will take more break
mmm-hmm
[Music]
guys a genius he cooks like an angel
he hasn't got all the fixtures and
fittings and the posh address but ye has
got is an amazing palette and for me
somebody to watch very closely for a
zoom and Momo my coat trip was like
being hit by hurricane however they both
came through and they're still standing
strong now I've invited into my office
to meet up with the help of secret
diners I've uncovered how these
restaurants perform when they think I'm
not around I send top food critic Simon
Davies to Momo undercover hoping that
improve on their service problems off I
left MoMA I sent in my secret diners and
they filmed your restaurants undercover
this is what happened Duncan Duncan we
need to be out of here in about our an
iPod or something
English good file or initiative it's
good let's go for the word pigeon in the
prawns and then we'll have I think a
tagine so we've seen two of the waiters
now sorry are you ready for the main one
I want at the same time no I mean I read
order that we've ordered all right are
you ready yeah sometimes we get
overwhelmed and we just like help each
other
yeah that's of course obviously here
lack of communication yeah but if
somebody's in a rush that gets set
across the board Toby but it doesn't in
terms of a steer I don't think it looks
wildly appetizer it looks a little bit
dry the wood pigeons been minced to such
a degree you can't distinguish it from
any other meat in my opinion I think
mincing up the word pigeon ISM is an
error
they didn't that in mints out that
little piece of work pager shouldn't
leave bones you know you know I for so
bloody day this bone yeah that's mine
things were tolls it yeah it booked it
took me to be honest with you just
happen every so often would be he's just
yeah Karen edition can I have a little
side order for burning yeah just a
little a little bit of tubulin it was
almost as if he was too lazy to deal
with us I wanted a little bowl of
tabbouleh
but it is a bit perplexing we've had two
occasions now whether it be in a mistake
because they're not communicating with
each other excuse me
I always seem to booty I want to do it
was time to be up to be honest with you
I'm now confused about what I've told
which waiter as mutter bullish thank you
so the Tiberias arrived but it was a
good ten minutes now to ask two
different waiters and it got delivered
by a third fragmented search as opposed
to two waiters looking after the meeting
job did for five times with five
different waiters it's a busy restaurant
and you know you've got to know we still
control it's no excuse
Babbitt filled our water up since we
arrived
I'm just gonna leave that there it's in
a very prominent position we'll just see
if they fill it up a little more water
it's over two hours it certainly water
and now I've asked for some but it still
hasn't come excuse me
have some water
the water
I've just got it's a Moroccan restaurant
doesn't mean we have the water retention
ability of a camel we've been waiting
our water they should be waiting that
long for water defeat note in for me to
wash toilets sorry yeah yeah
disappointing he's met so many waitress
and none of them noticed that doing the
water bus they won't answer but you are
somewhat over staffed with bodies there
when you've had the egg for ninth the
tenth waiter
Heather table you feel a bit sort of
Jesus we are just yeah I want to compare
both hand if he passed along to the next
person that's a restaurant dition
transport you to another place you can
eat good food that's the good food you
can have fun here and if going out and
eating our restaurant is about having
fun and excitement and sharing that with
your friends then this takes
the food's good bloody cute a few areas
of tightening up service needs to come
together glamorous great attentive
individuals but they need to play as a
team and then when the team's all seen
off that hem shape you've got one
amazing rest
but get constructive criticism you know
but can we sort it out that's what we
get therefore sometimes I used to hurt
the mouse but use get back up again is a
more stronger
it's the North African heat of my best
restaurant competition and charming
family run a zoo from West London are
going head to head with central London
sled a giant Momo
don't start 14 or start six-year please
leave him alone
ha he's fine now it's the turn of a zoo
to hear some difficult home truce
thanks to my undercover secret diner
food and recipe writer Sarah Durden
Robertson has traveled in North Africa
and sampled the cuisine firsthand as you
will have to be on top form to impress
her what I'd like to tell you that
you've actually been tested twice a
bleep that's news my undercover team I
went to your restaurant and this is what
happens hello
table for two Duncan yes please
[Music]
maybe I well maybe the sardines and the
olives surfing thank you hi do you know
what could I swap two of those sorry you
must be good enough for me
Oh could I have the prawns there instead
and the Burak
okay if you could ask okay if the
customer changes their mind that's their
prager tip because they're paying well
and we have to show that level of
flexibility about what's already done
the Saudis she sort of you bailed on me
gosh that was very quick okay but could
I still do you mind if I still change
change worth so I'd like to not have the
sardines
[Music]
okay but can i order something else as
an extra order then could I just have
the Burak yes
rule number one never humiliate a
customer yeah I had already she'd been
made to feel vulnerable yeah quite a
very silly yeah because she just wanted
to change her dish oh yes I'm sorry this
is just a bit too spicy for me that is
the in the menu it's spicy hot yes I
know I know and he did say yes but I
thought I'd actually just tea spicy for
me
[Music]
this one okay yeah wrong when Cass was
arriving arrested for the very first
time
yeah and they make a mistake on their
order yeah we have to be prepared to
change you want the customers to come
back right yeah watch what happens next
this one ice take away maybe it can have
it tomorrow
ah that's really kind thank you
yes coz I've hardly touched it very good
thank you
[Music]
no that's incredibly quick how did you
do that well you have to do it with him
it in the same time so I just had to
speed the process thank you thank you so
much
this is absolutely delicious I have been
to Marrakesh some of the best food I've
ever had and just takes me right back so
you pulled it back in a very charming
way see and look at the difference in
what happened when we changed that dish
amazing I love this place Chris is
amazing so charming your customers are
in love with you and your food okay and
if you want to charge them ring me up
I'll pay for the [ __ ] dish okay
I've gotta go Jim I trust my team I
believe in my team and that did happened
it won't happen again and that's it now
is let's see what's coming ahead
[Music]
Izumo I found my test really tough but
honestly I do admire their fighting
spirit now it's time for the final
challenge as both teams cross London to
come and cook in my flagship restaurant
and this is a very last chance they've
got to shine
if the test is to create one mind-blown
dish worthy of my michelin-starred
restaurant I wanted to really push
themselves and cook like they've never
done before only one restaurant to go
through to the semi-finals this is what
dreams are made of a farmer's boy I mean
I've lived as a butcher so this is this
is not to met him proud as well I want
to win I really want to him being in
Ramsay's restaurant it's an honor and
I'm very very happy I think I'm not on a
disappointing tonight it is very very
important day
welcome welcome good to see right during
this competition because both directions
are unique the excitement behind the
North African cuisine and what it can
deliver in textures flavors spice is
mind-blowing this is the dish of your
life right because this is what's gonna
kill upon one of you into the semi-final
make sure it's you good luck
I've asked them to come up with one
exquisite dish featuring lamb the star
ingredient of North African cuisine
one side with a zoo you've got
traditional and oversight with Momo you
got this new wave a light style of North
African cuisine and completely opposite
ends of the spectrum to help me choose
who's best
both teams creations will be served to
highly distinguished guests including
LCR wusu director of the Royal African
society Lobby Remi key head of culture
and press at the Moroccan Embassy and
distinguished Moroccan chef and
restauranteur Joseph Bell LT the front
of house teams from both restaurants are
also dining here today David is an
excellent chef I know everything's gonna
be delicious
it's like a holiday cooking for 20 I'm
usually cooking for 200 itself should
technically be a walk in the park it's
an enormous challenge I think he will
cope very well okay
hummus where is the hummus gotta have a
dream don't sit my one big concern today
with azureus he's been so used to
cooking these little Bowl it's a
completely different set and today I
didn't get the better of him he just
stays focus but you little bit lost in
the kitchen with all the space are we
happy with something I'm gonna be fine
XS
[Music]
chris is cooking a traditional spicy
lamb tagine so with couscous but he's
not stopping there I also cook a
stunning lamb dish and gone the extra
mile and making bread right the
authentic semolina bread will be served
with fresh hummus a unique spice mixture
of tomatoes roasted peppers chillies and
coriander pick up a table for lamb
tagine yes sir
Momo for stunning lamb yes yeah yeah
thank you
David Romano is preparing a delicious
roast loin of lamb with aubergine ragout
barley couscous and a lamb's liver with
harissa wrapped in spinach and
deep-fried in tempura batter I want to
do something else in North African
Student I want to show the next level
the next dimension we can go loves over
tempura and you're wrapping the liver
yes with spinach deep-fry hopefully it's
about 50 51 seconds yeah the time get
lost time twice so you already are
pushing about in a big way it's
incredible it's pushing the boundary out
with the Lambs liver which is not
everyone's cup of tea
I just hope an hour's time that doesn't
go back to buy him on the ass give me an
estimated time for 45 minutes max chef
if there's ever a night to work as a
team this is it but as the pressure
builds crisp is up these old tricks just
make it ready for me I'll show you first
no open he's such a control freak wait
wait I check it can't stop and he can't
help themselves he wants to do
everything
no no you go touch the plate yep okay
Azusa first dishes hit the pass but
within minutes Jesus oh that was quick
okay so this please
first table coming out Rob let's go Izu
yeah shuttle cover several six mass
Chris yes chef
it's dinner yeah take your time yes I
had Portland chef service please let's
go
chris is cooking faster than [ __ ]
Usain Bolt runs he's just totally
focused refuses to talk to me and he's
head is steeped right in that couscous
I'm fourth person here we are thank you
let's go
[Music]
amazing really
the Reddy's brother said mother my
grandmother that's happening the sus was
too much sauce for me ready for my test
yeah yeah
chef David's modern take on North
African cuisine it's a lot more
sophisticated seven upset yeah the five
elements to his dish required delicate
timing and sous-chef Phillip is getting
ahead of himself don't slice too soon
I'm already know ready chef and already
don't go yeah I'll give you 90 seconds
before I wonder laughs come on listen to
David Philippe
slow down please don't slice that lamb
too early yeah when Debbie gives you the
call yeah all in that juice yeah in
amongst that couscous not left on the
board yes yeah please enjoy Philip you
can leave it resting here leave it fat
side down like that yeah I was gonna do
is render and it stay nice and warm see
I'm saying thank you yeah yes slow that
one don't you yeah Jeff's well that one
down yes at this stage in competition
David can't afford to make mistakes
Billy yeah one more over G once I'm good
two more over G
to get every dish perfect Momo need to
pull together as a team cuz cuz
yes confident get my hand dressing as
well please yes yes yeah like a proper
teamwork good in the middle same work
off boat race there you yes
[Music]
and they've pulled it off David they
look fantastic very nice of people
colors okay service please
raise up please Table two please yes
[Music]
fantastic people make your pig food see
there's just that musty smoky feel it's
something a bit different we kind of all
agreed that livers not a favorite thing
on the list but the way it is the last
of Chris's exquisite tagines are flying
out of the kitchen
thank here's just one table to serve
anyway our next chef has smells amazing
delicious Gil that was fast
was good next yeah breathe take some
fresh air last a Waldo yes
that's what the filter father more than
service is over and it's time to find
out what my distinguished guests think
about these two extraordinary dishes
starting with a zoo right how is your
lamb shank the lamb Shack was my
favorite it's really soon as I
experience that source I knew that was
it
authentic and delicious I just enjoyed
it for what it was very simple perfectly
blended I dip the bread in first
mouthful oh I like them both but I
thought the the Momo dish was fresh it
was beautifully presented
it was just together delightful I prefer
the zoo dish you could just imagine
yourself being in the old souk
definitely I prefer them in most dish
because the meat was very well cooked
I'm used to Moroccan cuisine because I'm
Moroccan myself so it is really a sort
of cuisine the temporal ever I was not
expecting it to be quite as
mouth-wateringly sort of melts on the
tongue as it was it was really really
delicious I love the zoo dish I adore
the flavors they were so powerful I
wanted more my diners comments confirmed
the brilliance of the food served here
by both the zoo and Momo I'm very happy
I'm happy
well those new improvements but what
made me proud is we've come together I'm
really proud Thank You chef
both these teams of amazing chefs have
approached North African cuisine in very
different ways let's see if the
traditional is runner to beat the modern
that's of the condition life is better
now I have an incredibly difficult
decision to make because only one
wrestler can go through to the
semi-finals my two top North African
contenders
momona xue both from London have thrown
everything at the final challenge
they are both outstanding restaurants
but over the course of my three tests
that both made mistakes I'm about to
tell one of them they've cooked in this
competition for the last time tell me
make my choice I need to taste both
dishes starting with David's from Momo
it looks modern 21st century and
stunning very pretty almost too pretty
for North African cuisine Lambs
delicious I mean really delicious
delicate truck beautifully liver
difficult to get right not only that
best tempered and you don't think of
sort of m5 liver with North African
cuisine however the combination of
Arusha and the barley couscous works
brilliantly well I would an issue with a
liver however the lamb is cooked
perfectly and it's a loin of lamb so
it's it's been shown respect authentic
classic untouched meat falling off the
bone
[Music]
that's delicious really delicious
lamb is just melting your mouth it needs
to be a little bit more trimmed excess
fat removed however sauce is incredible
you can see there's 30 years experience
into that because it's just packed full
of flavor this is such an amazing
contrast and Momo's interpretation is
modern fresh fragrant delivers a big
punch uncertain about the liver
everything else it is delicious as oozes
rich authentic and just steeped with
passion like him and right now it's I'm
stuck to go forward with a modernization
of North African cuisine or do I stay in
the history of something classically
done it's too tight to call
- fantastic North African restaurants
[Music]
but only one can win a place in the
semi-final
[Music]
what
what I saw today was two completely
different dishes but done with pride
history and innovation a zoo
you've stuck to your roots I think
you're back in I'll do yes and you're
back with your mother and your your
grandma and you were you were there yes
sure I could identify the authenticity
the classic style and the richness of
that beautiful David it's very rare to
find a British chef cooking out of his
comfort zone but tonight you came and
you he moved the goalposts he modernized
North African cuisine I was done with
Flair which I didn't expect you to do
however this round is not won on a
single dish just think of the journey so
far in this competition go back to the
coach load of dinars turning up all at
the same time the pressure of serving
all those guests in under two hours was
a nightmare then all of a sudden you can
let your hair down and let's get back to
cooking and then you've been secretly
filmed both restaurants came through
that test and they both had their highs
and both have their lows listening to
the diner's tasting both dishes based on
everything we've done in this
competition
the restaurant going through to the
semi-finals
[Music]
congratulations to
[Music]
Davis don't stop that level of pushing
to the extreme all done thank you well
done
I'm good at the moment but I've got a
lot of fight left in me
give me of a chance first to me again
congratulations yeah very very proud so
pleased is he you know it means such a
lot I'm sorry to see Mamo go David is a
brave and passionate chef who is pushing
the boundaries of North African cuisine
but a zoom are a truly fabulous
restaurant and I can't wait to go back
there that's why they've gone through
why now this competition only gonna get
tougher and I hope they don't let me
down